[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 les titres de ce
lundi 18 septembre c'est la semaine
européenne de la mobilité sept jours
pour bouger autrement yvelinois comme
collectivités participent à l'opération
notamment le parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse qui l'ont son
défi mobilité
on en parle avec julie qui seront
chargés de mission pnr les élections
sénatoriales sont au programme dimanche
prochain 170 parlementaires seront élus
parmi lesquels six sénateur des yvelines
comment fonctionne le scrutin qui sont
les candidats dans le département
chronique dans cette édition
et puis c'était ce week-end les journées
européennes du patrimoine convie chaque
année petits et grands à la découverte
des trésors du territoire en fin de
journal retour sur les événements
organisés à saint quentin en yvelines
avant d'ouvrir ce journal il était en
poste depuis mai 2016 didier guillemot
quitte la présidence de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
le professeur a décidé de démissionner
de ses fonctions suite un événement
accidentel sérieux et a jugé nécessaire
de se consacrer à sa guérison
c'est le professeur alain buis qui prend
la succession de didier guillemot
présidence par intérim avec la charge
d'organiser une élection en interne au
conseil d'administration propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude les statuts prévoient que
j'assure en tant que vice-président du
conseil d'administration les fonctions
de président par intérim et donc d'une
part pour assurer le bon fonctionnement
de
université durant cette période là est
aussi d'organiser les élections dans un
délai d'un mois des élections par le
conseil d'administration du nouveau
président un dossier important sur le
feu notamment l'élaboration du plan
quinquennal de l'ue vs qu est la
construction du budget 2018 le nom du
nouveau président devrait être connu
avant le 14 octobre prochain
l'université vino a justement fait le
plein d'étudiants étrangers chaque année
ils sont plus de 1500 à faire leur
rentrée dans l'établissement
et ce n'est pas toujours évident pour
les aider des semaines d'intégration
mélanie poquet et lé a réagi ont assisté
pour gabriel la rentrée scolaire va se
faire sous les couleurs françaises cet
étudiant brésilien de 19 ans a choisi la
france et plus particulièrement
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines pour son échange à
l'étranger
je choisis la france parce que la france
est une vraie puissance cantons actuels
en sciences humaines
cette renommée intellectuelle lu vs qu
l'entretien à travers plus de 200
formations réunies sur cinq campus
l'année 2010 est signe même son grand
retour au classement de shanghaï
puisqu'elle est élevée au 40e rang
mondial en sciences de la terre des
méthodes d'enseignement qui paie mais
pas toujours évidente à intégrer
l'amphithéâtre c'est une chose nouvelle
brazès et ce dans les salles plus petit
avec des cours plus petit
c'est une nouvelle expérience aussi bas
les lectures parce que ici on l'a on lit
des livres
le président lit des différents
chapitres de beaucoup des livres on n'y
parle en livrant tiers pour accompagner
les étudiants une semaine d'intégration
est organisée au programme animations et
rencontres comme le language dating
ils ont ainsi l'occasion de nouer des
liens avec leurs homologues français
même si aujourd'hui du véhicule ne peut
donner suite à tous les dossiers de
candidature ils sont nombreux chaque
année à rejoindre les bancs de
l'université à lui vs qu on a environ
10% des étudiants étrangers donc ça me
fait ça représente entre 1800 et 2000
étudiants à l'année enfin selon les
années et puis on a aussi les étudiants
qui viennent en programme des changes
comme erasmus par exemple est donc là ça
représente entre 100 et 150 étudiants à
l'année association sportive littéraires
musicales et bien d'autres
les nouveaux arrivants sont entre de
bonnes mains autre offre d'enseignement
supérieur sur le territoire l'estaca
dont le campus paris saclay est situé à
montigny le bretonneux l'école
d'ingénieurs postbac cas spécialisé dans
les transports et la mobilité bouge
justement elle propose à ses étudiants
depuis la rentrée un parcours bi
diplômant possibilité de suivre un
double cursus estaca centrale supélec
aux estacades centrale à casablanca pour
en parler avec nous à pascal bidan
bonsoir bonsoir et vous êtes le
directeur délégué du campus de l'estaca
à saint quentin en yvelines en yvelines
alors ce diplôme résulte d'une
convention signée avec justement
centrale supélec et centrale
casablanca c'est c'est important oui de
collaborer avec d'autres écoles passe
quelque chose de primordial
oui c'est primordial de collaborer sept
parcours bi diplômant nous l'ouvrons
pour la rentrée scolaire de septembre
2017 et cette rentrée scolaire elle
s'inscrit dans une double din est
dynamique double dynamique positive de
l'estaca une festa cas c'est une école
d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans les
transports et la mobilité double
dynamique parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
manquons d'ingénieurs en france il
faudrait former à peu près 200 mille
ingénieurs en france c'est 135 mille
donc 50 pour ça en plus
et puis d'autre part parce qu'il ya une
dynamique extrêmement importantes dans
les transports et la mobilité la semaine
de mobilité aujourd'hui
et moi nous on en parlera tout à l'heure
les assises de la mobilité le coup
d'envoi sera donné demain donc
aujourd'hui le campus de saint quentin
de l'istac à deux ans après son
ouverture est plein nous avons 1400
étudiants
ce recrutement d'étudiants s'est fait
également en améliorant le niveau de nos
étudiants et ce sont au vert finalement
voilà les signaux sont ouverts et donc
ce parcours bi diplômant permet à nos
étudiants donc un certain nombre de nos
meilleurs étudiants d'avoir un double
diplôme
donc nos diplômes d'ingénieurs estaca
mais également d'avoir un diplôme de
spécialités de centrale type était
justement pourquoi offrir cette
possibilité à vos étudiants d'avoir ce
double cursus diddy club à la fin de
l'heure de leur étude du coup alors
c'est quelque chose déjà démarré il ya
cinq ans notre l'estac a fait partie du
groupe
il a eu de groupe 01 regroupe les quatre
écoles qui sont les écoles d'excellence
dans le secteur aéronautique et spatial
donc lisa e super héros à toulouse les
avancements à poitiers l'école de l'air
à salon de provence et puis et puis
l'estac a donc là ça nous permettait à
des étudiants ingénieurs de l'estaca de
l'aéronautique d'avoir également une
spécialisation à super héros et pour les
étudiants de l'automobile ou du
ferroviaire et on prolonge cette action
avec la possibilité d'avoir ce double
diplôme donc à générer staka et puis
spécialisation à centrale type là non ça
peut être un diplôme obtenu à centrale
supélec qui vient de déménager sur le
plateau de saclay où ça peut être
également dans les autres campus le
campus de rennes par exemple de centrale
supélec ou à l'international
donc avec l'escale de l'antarctique hall
central casablanca alors vous en avez
dire un mot ça s'adresse à un certain
nombre de vos étudiants concrètement
comment va se passer ce parcours
finalement quand il commence là ils vont
commencer tout juste à cette rentrée
2010 est comment ça se passe ce parcours
tout à fait alors cette spécialisation
elle est offerte en dernière année mon
cinquième année sa liste haka est une
école en cinq ans donc nous recrutons la
plupart de nos étudiants post bac
on recrute aussi quelques étudiants une
petite centaine en classe préparatoire
donc y retrouver un cursus en troisième
année
et puis donc en 5e année ils ont la
possibilité
faire sept dernières années donc soit à
l'international on a une aujourd'hui un
accord avec 40 partenaires d'université
à l'international soit dans le groupe
isa eux pour l'aéronautique soit donc à
centrale casablanca donc à une double
sélection
une sélection qui est fait par l'estac a
principalement sur les résultats
académiques mais aussi la capacité à
s'intégrer à porter aussi la notoriété
de l'estaca centrale supélec ou wise as
eu ou à l'international
et puis après il ya une deuxième
sélection qui est fait donc part par
centrale supélec pour ce double diplôme
et du coup pour ses doubles diplômes ce
parcours bi diplômant il ya plusieurs
parcours possible quatre parcours donc
voila tout à fait on a aujourd'hui un
accord sous quatre spécialités dont qui
vont du génie industriel
donc tout ce qui est lié à l usine du
futur le process quatre points du sinn
4.0 comment te moderniser tout le
process industriel tous y aller à
l'énergie on a également beaucoup
d'action d'innovation sur l'énergie
l'énergie électrique l'hybridation des
sources
l'hydrogène donc là aussi c'est une
action qui est fait en collaboration
avec les laboratoires de centrale
supélec et puis une une spécialisation
toutes orientées mécanique d'accord donc
donc en fonction des des envies de nos
étudiants c'est également une action
importante de pouvoir spécialisé en fait
le cursus d'un étudiant à l'estac ali à
des matières qui sont indispensables
et puis il ya des options des cours
électifs et donc en fonction des
motivations certaines vont créer une
entreprise et donc choisi de
l'entrepreneuriat d'autres veulent
absolument aller travailler à l'étranger
et donc font des stages à l'étranger ou
vont faire une année d'études dans nos
partenaires internationaux et puis
certains vont à centrale supélec là
aussi c'est un parcours qui de plus en
plus individualisée en fonction des
attentes de
nous étudions merci pascal bilan d'abord
avec nos jeux rappelle directeur délégué
du campus de l'estac à saint quentin en
yvelines et pour plus d'infos sur ce
parcours bi diplômant rendez vous sur le
site internet de l'estaca qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran on accueille sur ce
plateau à nicolas landry bonsoir vous
allez nous parler de ce dernier scrutin
pour l'année 2010 est sont les
sénatoriales 170 parlementaires vont
être élus ce dimanche 24 septembre et
notamment pour occuper les six sièges
des yvelines qui seront renouvelées
comment qui sont pardon qui sont pour
commencer on va on va qu on va leur
apprendre à les connaître
qui sont les sénateurs sortants des
yvelines alors vous allez les voir à
l'image quatre sénateurs républicains et
deux sénateurs à part apparenté à gauche
parmi eux on retrouve évidemment le
président du sénat gérard larcher
un mandat qu'il assure depuis 2014 et
qu'il avait déjà détenus entre 2008 et
alors c'est un scrutin parfois méconnus
par les français
comment sont élus ces parlementaires
alors écoutez grégory vous n'aurez pas
besoin de vous déplacer aux urnes de ce
dimanche tout comme moi d'ailleurs et
certains de nos téléspectateurs
c'est une élection au suffrage universel
indirect c'est à dire que seuls les
grands électeurs sont appelés
obligatoirement aux urnes ils sont près
de 3000 dans les yvelines
parmi eux on retrouve les députés les
sénateurs sortants les conseillers
régionaux et départementaux ainsi que
des délégués municipaux dans les
yvelines six sièges sont à pourvoir et
particularités de ce scrutin
il est proportionnel et plurinominal les
grands électeurs vont voter en fait pour
des listes et les les distributions des
sièges se fait proportionnellement par
exemple pour gagner un siège dans les
yvelines il faut obtenir un minimum de
486 voix si vous en obtenez le doute
vous gagné deux sièges et ainsi de suite
et les sièges restants sont attribués à
la plus forte moyenne
et quelles sont les missions du sénateur
finalement alors les sénateurs sont élus
pour six ans avec un renouvellement par
moitié tous les trois ans il représente
les collectivités territoriales et comme
les députés il contrôler l'action du
gouvernement fabrique discute et votent
les lois
dernière chose nicolas quelles sont les
candidats qui sont les candidats pour
ces élections qui auront lieu ce
dimanche 12 17 ont été déposées pour ce
scrutin est le principal enjeu les
républicains vont ils conserver leurs
sièges et même accroître leur nombre
alors au vu de la composition du corps
électoral c'est-à-dire de la couleur
politique des grands électeurs la liste
de gérard larcher part favori mais
attention malgré tout aux autres listes
apparentées à droite comme celle de
jacques milliard de jeunes viêt salsa ou
de jean-frédéric berceau autre enjeu la
gauche va-t-elle de conserver un au
moins un siège
là aussi la division règne quatre listes
au total écoutez eddie ait président du
parti radical de gauche des yvelines
c'est vrai qu'il ya un risque politique
parce que la gauche ne dispose pas de
sénateur mais il faut croire que les
conditions qui avaient été réunis au
précédent scrutin d'un large
rassemblement à gauche sur une base
programmatique et idéologique n'ont pas
été réunis cette fois ci puis nous
avions décidé de prendre nos
responsabilités parce que nous avions
des engagements nous avions des réserves
vis-à-vis du gouvernement
nous avions des réserves vis-à-vis des
positions exprimées par une partie de la
gauche
puis nous avons notre propre identité
alors en embuscade on retrouve la
république en marche une liste composée
sans le modem contrairement aux
élections législatives le parti de
françois bayrou s'est allié à lui des
ide dans les yvelines
de son côté le front national va tenter
aussi d'obtenir au moins un siège avec
des positions très tranchées sur les
collectivités territoriales
écoutez yasmine belmadi l'objectif c'est
déjà de redonner du pouvoir aux
collectivités locales que sont la mairie
et le département
parce que pour nous c'est vraiment le
socle c'est ce qui fait la france est ce
qui fait le maillage territorial
notre objectif effectivement c'est la
suppression de la région merci nicolas
pour ces précisions le rappel est lié à
sénatoriales c'est au programme dimanche
prochain ils ont du mal à ils ont du mal
souvent à durer dans les centres villes
et les centres bourgs les commerces de
proximité cherche à se redynamiser l
association des commerçants et artisans
de la commune vient de lancer un
chéquier avantage opération qui se
prolongera jusqu'au 15 novembre principe
des réductions et promotions dans une
trentaine de boutiques mort pas yens
les détails au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude invités
les habitants à venir nous rendre visite
dans nos commerces
on a besoin de faire revivre justement
le centre de maurepas et les alentours
puisqu'il ya aussi des commerces aux
alentours du centre ville qui ont
participé environ 8500 chez qui ont été
distribués et 1500 été répartis dans
tous les commerces qui ont participé à
l'opération à distribuer aux éventuels
clients en dehors de la ville des
chéquiers similaires à ceux de maurepas
ont déjà été expérimentées par les
commerçants de voisins-le-bretonneux et
de plaisir et jusqu'à vendredi c'est la
semaine européenne de la mobilité elle
incite à réfléchir sur de nouvelles
manières de se déplacer
le but étant de faire changer les
comportements plusieurs collectivités
participent au rendez vous notamment à
saint quentin en yvelines ou des forums
se tiennent dans les entreprises
technocentre renault thalès airbus par
exemple et puis d'autres initiatives
comme celle ci depuis une semaine 50
franciliens se sont lancés dans le défi
trois semaines sans voitures organisée
par la mairie de paris
objectif se passer de son véhicule et
n'utiliser que des transports de
substitution et mélanie poquet et
camille lambert ont suivi alain à des
candidats qui a fait le trajet tous les
matins depuis à aiguille en cours
ce geste c'est devenu une habitude pour
florent prendre le train déplier son
vélo électrique une routine installé
depuis une semaine
comme une cinquantaine de participants
il s'est lancé dans le défi trois
semaines sans voiture j'adopte la
multimodalité
donc c'est à dire que je prends mon je
prends mon vélo de chez moi jusqu'à la
gare montparnasse
ensuite je prends un jeu pour le ter qui
arrive à la gare de versailles chantiers
ici et ensuite je réutilise ce vélo donc
qui est électrique pour faire les 8
derniers kilomètres qui me sépare de mon
lieu de travail donc un transport je
mettais à peu près une heure 18h15 et en
voiture une heure vingt à peu près par
par trajet aujourd'hui la avec le vélo
train vélo je mets à peu près 55 9 un
gain de temps et une source de pollution
en moins
le vélo électrique permet aussi de moins
se fatiguer il est prêté par
l'association we move partenaires de
l'opération
les coaches reste en contact avec les
candidats pour se soutenir et régler les
différents problèmes rencontrés malgré
un souci de crevaisons et une panne
florent reste convaincu j'hésitais déjà
avant le défi je me posais la question
est là le fait d'en avoir un en prêt
pendant trois semaines a fini de
convaincre et ça va être un maître
futurs investissements
dès que le porte monnaie
le permet pour ce type de modèle il
faudra compter dans les 800 euros
certains peuvent aller jusqu'à 2000 la
mairie de paris organisatrice du défi
offre une subvention pour les acheteurs
lui est un habitué des opérations sur la
mobilité le parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse lens sont des
filles mobilité dix semaines pour
réduire sa consommation de carburant et
tester des alternatives à l'automobile
bon soir julie tisseron vous êtes chargé
de mission écomobilité au pnr de la
haute vallée de chevreuse alors le pnr
je les dis non n'est pas à son coup
d'essai une autre opération par exemple
ces sept jours sans voiture aujourd'hui
ce défi mobilité pourquoi finalement
lancer ce genre d'initiative alors mass
effectivement dans la continuité dc dur
sans voiture qu'on a mené depuis 2015
l'idée c'est de sensibiliser la
population à la pac de la voiture
individuelle sur l'environnement et donc
de faire la promotion des modes de
transports alternatifs
donc ce défi poursuit l'initiative de
départ du parc naturel et là cette année
on est en partenariat avec l'agencé
locale de l'énergie de saint quentin en
yvelines pour lancer donc un défi sur
dix semaines donc là on est plus sur
sept jours mais vraiment sur 10 semaines
et l'objectif c'est de changer les
comportements
liés aux déplacements sur la durée donc
voilà dix semaines on a estimé que
c'était suffisant voilà mais c'est serré
raisonnable pour y arriver c'est
jusqu'au 24 novembre du défi c'est de
réduire sa consommation de carburant et
donc tester des des alternatives à la
voiture
concrètement comment ça va se passer
pour les participants pendant ces 10
semaines de déçus alors durant ces 10
semaines il va y avoir un accompagnement
du parc de l'alec voilà tout au long
pour suivre un petit peu leur
déplacement est également ils vont avoir
des offres qui vont leur être proposées
pour tester dû par exemple des vélos à
assistance électrique avoir des tickets
de transports en commun gratuits tester
des applications d'auto-stop connecter
pour tester le covoiturage donc là
l'idée c'est vraiment qui se lance un
challenge à la fois personnel et en
équipe parce qu'on a voulu que ce soit
en équipe au ccri un candidat t on peut
y participer en équipe avec sa famille
ses amis ses collègues
voilà là c'est un peu la différence des
autres années où les participants
étaient en solo dans ceux qui
poursuivent l'aventuré plutôt en équipe
pour voir s'essoufler sur la durée
puisque dix semaines c'est assez long
donc on a estimé qu'on équipe c'était
plus intéressant et motivant
donc il voit là ils sont prêts à ce jour
on a 17 inscrits on en attend encore une
bonne dizaine voire plus et on voit que
l'engouement est toujours là donc on est
ravi de renoncer ça qu'est ce que ces
équipes finalement on a gagné c'est
aussi d'apprendre des choses finalement
pourquoi mais voilà c'est d'apprendre
des choses ça va ce qui se passe sur le
territoire en termes d'alternatives
trouver sa propre alternative de
mobilité souvent on croit savoir ce qui
se passe et autour de chez soi et savoir
par exemple toutes les lignes de bus qui
existent toutes les plateformes de
covoiturage ou autre et on peut
découvrir de nouvelles choses donc c'est
aussi ça l'objectif d'apprendre et à la
fin ils seront récompensés de leurs
efforts puisqu'on prévoit des malades et
des lots des récompenses venant de la
part du parquet de la lègue de saint
quentin
donc c'est un défi à la fois personnel
et puis voilà une récompense à la fin de
l'opération
alors comment des participants
concrètement alors sa fille voilà on
s'inscrit en ligne sur le site du parc
naturel ou de l'alec ont rempli un petit
formulaire et ensuite on contacte chaque
participant et
chacun reçoit chez soi de la
documentation et un petit kit de
mobilité pour avoir toutes les
informations
site internet dont parlait d'ailleurs
qu'il s'affiche pour nos téléspectateurs
en bas de l'écran juste province
d'accord du parc naturel effectivement
et voilà il me suit l'aventuré lancée
dernière question pour donner envie aux
personnes participent et pourquoi
participer au défi mobilité alors déjà
je pense que c'est un engagement
personnel de se lancer dans un défi
quand même convivial parce qu'on veut
avant tout vraiment convivial que ça se
fasse dans la bonne humeur et l'envié
simplement de participer
allah allah contre le changement
climatique en fait tout simplement donc
c'est aussi ça y avant tout l'objectif
de ce défi merci je l'utiliseront
d'avoir une eau chargée de mission
écomobilité au pnr de la haute vallée de
chevreuse le défi mobilité c'est
jusqu'au 24 novembre et pour plus
d'informations vous avez le site
internet du parc naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse et puisqu'on parlait
du pnr de la haute vallée de chevreuse
le programme n'était riche ce week-end
les journées européennes du patrimoine
se tenait donc ce week-end et du côté
d'el en cours samedi une visite
originale du quartier 17 mar étaient
proposées l'api manif on sait par david
rolland chorégraphe basée à rennes dans
le cadre d'un partenariat entre le musée
de la ville et le prisme mélanie poker
casque sur les oreilles les voilà équipé
ses visiteurs vont participer à une api
manif une déambulation dans le quartier
17 mar pensé par le chorégraphe david
rolland nous lui avons demandé une api
manif spécialement écrite qui sait qu'il
s'appelle la croisée des arts entre
culture et patrimoine
donc c'est le travail qu'il a fait en
partenariat avec le musée de la ville
qui lui a donné énormément de
renseignement il a écrit cette partition
c'est un quartier des années 70 qui a
été inaugurée en 76 et il ya toute une
architecture qu'on a peut-être oublié
dans ce quartier au temps des immeubles
que des objets d'art qui sont situés
autour pendant que vous vous éparpillez
on écoute ma dame des landes architecte
avec son mari du quartier 17 mar et donc
on est partis tous les deux venise et on
a mesuré toutes les places qu'ils nous
trouvent une quarantaine de minutes de
voyage dans le quartier lors de cette
journée du patrimoine
les haltes historiques se sont mêlés aux
instances culturelles comme celle
sculptures de klaus schulz la main
divine
elle s'appelle c'est un homme puis
d'ordre et qui rêve et il est absolument
calme il n'y a rien du tout autour de
lui et
très surprenant donc la particularité
c'est vrai que chirac a donc été isolé
d'une certaine façon et on était tous
ensemble en même temps dans le principe
on a découvert dans que le quartier de
cette marque que je connaissais pas du
tout et est intéressant aussi c'est de
découvrir des éléments de l'architecturé
c'est à dire de danser dans l'espace
avec les autres et dans cet espace
urbain
une cinquantaine de participants ont
dansé à travers les allées élan
courtoise pour terminer sur une
chorégraphie énergisante toujours dans
le cadre des journées européennes du
patrimoine à saint quentin en yvelines
l'enfant dans la ville c'est le nom de
cette exposition présente ce week-end à
l'espace de covile de
voisins-le-bretonneux collections du
musée de la ville autour de la place de
l'enfant dans les années 1970 au moment
de la création de la ville nouvelle
explications recueillies par à nicolas
dans prix c'est l'époque du baby-boom
aussi donc beaucoup de jeunes familles
qui ont besoin de logements plus grands
qui ont besoin de plus d espace qui
viennent donc dans cette ville nouvelle
de saint quentin en yvelines dans
laquelle la question de la prise en
charge de l'enfance est crucial et on a
des aménagements ici particulièrement
pensé pour les enfants notamment en
termes de jardin public de jeu et
d'écoles d'équipements scolaires mais
aussi une maison de quartier et de deux
structures de prise en charge de
l'enfance et pour ces journées du
patrimoine les stars ce sont bien sûr
les monuments et des édifices parfois en
péril qu'il convient d'entretenir à ce
propos le maire dvd de versailles
françois de mazières vient d'interpeller
la française des jeux
elle et lui demande la création d'un
tirage spécial du loto pour financer la
restauration des sites en danger
l édile milite par exemple pour des jeux
à gratter à l'éffigie des monuments
célèbres une proposition utile à ses
yeux dans un contexte de baisse des
financements publics
on referme ce journal par du sport en
rugby le club de plaisir jouer ce
week-end son premier match de
championnat de fédérale 2
deux ans justement après avoir quitté
cette division est les plaisirs oise se
sont lourdement inclinés 47 à 17 contre
bobigny retour sur la rencontre avec
nicolas landry et micheline milot
pour son retour en fédérale 2 plaisir
qui évolue en jaune et bleu avec une
partie compliquée contre bobigny ce
dimanche 17 septembre les plaisirs oies
se sont inclinés sur leur pelouse 47 à
17 en encaissant un terrible 40 à 3 en
première période
c'est une équipe qui a beaucoup de plus
d'expérience que nous au niveau je
rappelle que c'est en fédérale 2 l'année
dernière quand même et
et c'est vrai que dès qu'on se consommer
un petit peu trop sur les phases de ruck
où six a raté un plaquage m'a tout de
suite ça faisait la différence ça jouer
dans le dos parce qu'on n'était pas
forcément capable de faire
collectivement on était on était pas mal
en place malheureusement
individuellement on a fait vraiment des
grosses fautes de défense
et puis bah face à une très belle équipe
comme ça avec les joueurs rapides qu'ils
avaient forcément on a pris beaucoup
d'essais donc là la mi-temps ça faisait
cher quand même
de retour des vestiaires le père serre
montrer un autre visage devant son
public les plaisirs ont marqué deux
essais en 40 minutes contre un essai
pour bobigny
on vient de la deuxième mi-temps alors
après ce que
on baisser un petit peu le rythme ou ce
qu'ils ont fait tourner au je sais pas
en tout cas on a essayé de montrer un
peu plus fière allure et
bon du coup ça a payé faux sauf que sans
s'accrocher à ce à quoi il faudra
s'inspirer de cette seconde période dès
dimanche prochain plaisir se déplacera
sur le terrain de drancy une équipe qui
avait engrangé une victoire dans ce
championnat de fédérale 2 c'est la fin
de ce set 8 journal c'est à retrouver en
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile la tv
78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]